all right abby is with us and let's see
here abby is
in san francisco hi abby hi dave
hi dr dolan how's it going great how can
we help
uh yeah so i just wrote down uh one
question that i had and i would love to
get your opinion on it and i would like
you to answer it as though i was your
son and you wanted me to
and you were coaching me like that
that's how i answer them
all right awesome uh but before i
started i just wanted to mention dr d
i love your show i love the rocket
diario stickers and horse glasses stuff
keep it going that's all i'm gonna say
all right thank you
so i'm on baby step number three and my
safety net is fifty thousand dollars
and i will get there by the end of the
year my partner and i are moving towards
fiance status
so if we get married our combined income
will be 210 000
per year pre-tax she's having a hard
time
understanding why credit cards are bad
and why i would like
not to have credit cards in my future
family she wants to keep a credit card
around
in the off chance that we go through our
emergency fund
for any reason and preparing to get sick
and she really wants to go visit them
so if i was your son how would you
address this problem with my fiance
girlfriend if she's unwilling to draw a
line with their family
and kind of basically basically told me
i'll do whatever i need to do
in order to take care of my extended
family even if it means putting my
future family in bed and stuff like that
and i just wanted to ask if dr delany
could speak about how does uh
her cultural heritage uh we're both uh
indian so it's like we always take care
of our family and
all that stuff and i'm fine with that
but i'm just trying to understand
like if dr dolani had this issue how
would he deal with it how he convinced
his wife to go against the norm as well
let's talk about the money part first
well the the thing is this
where someone says if it bankrupts my
current
family because of cultural norms i'm
willing to do that to take care of my
extended family
i i i don't necessarily believe
that flex um that sounds like somebody
trying to let you know
before we get married that my family is
everything to me and
um if someone's truly saying that then
that's somebody that i'm going to be
apprehensive
about tying myself to because they are
telling me up front
you're not a jumper you're the least
important person in my life
right um of those i love you're at the
bottom right and if our kids come along
they're going to be at the bottom too
that also sounds like a grandiose
statement that somebody who's not yet
engaged not yet married makes
um i'm gonna do this and this and this
well congratulations you know you're not
right you've never held your baby right
um but i i i think it comes back there's
there's a level of fear that she sounds
like she has
and yeah she addressed that with me as
well she said
you're asking me to do all these things
but we're not married so i'm fearful
that if you break up
then i'll be stuck in a situation where
i'm not totally aware of how to handle
it so i'm fine with that
but i'm just thinking like if we do get
made yeah in order for you to get
married you need to be in agreement
that's exactly right whatever whatever
the agreement is you need to be in
agreement because
not you know thinking you're going to
change someone after marriage either one
of you is a bad
bad bad plan that's right but now so
here's the thing
from a reality standpoint a mathematics
standpoint
if you make 210 000 a year and you have
70 000
in your emergency fund and you still
need a
credit card as a backup for a potential
emergency
that is not a mathematical fact that's a
psychosis right that's methodology
that's
that's a ridiculous fear that is not not
based in reality right
and so that that's silly yes is what
that comes down to so that's
screaming that i've got other kinds of
insecurities going on that we need to
understand
and sometimes that is someone a child is
told their whole life you will have have
it have a credit card for emergencies
have a credit card for emergencies and
you will take care of me and it's just a
matter of looking down at the math
no matter what happens you will take
care of me that's right yeah they're
told that too
absolutely they are so i think you got
to get on the same page man and start
way at the beginning addressing the
fears that she's bringing into this
relationship yeah
and um and you can't really expect her
to do things
you know well yeah yeah that's exactly
what we would do
hope that helps feels a little vague
sorry man